[Music]
one of the reasons you wanted to stop by
which is very cool is nba
uh uh 2k 13. yes uh this is a a terrific
video best-selling basketball video game
of all time
that's actually a fact i didn't make
that up
i'm the sexiest man in america
that's something i made up
we uh you you you love this video game
obviously and and people say this is the
best game
uh i just heard you say it uh
we have you brought a clip here to
demonstrate how great the action is and
you customize this a little bit did you
know and you can add people and they
actually look like themselves so
you'll see okay let's see who you added
let's i think we know what's going to
happen let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi well first of all it was a nice play
i i gave you the alley-oop so you and i
are incredibly insane right
my biggest complaint is what i do the
weird what am i doing after i score can
we see that again what's going on there
with my face after i score
yeah
[Laughter]
that's fine that's enough that's enough
i don't do that
okay maybe i do
you know what i will say about this game
i've played it and the game does very
accurately depict my basketball skills
perfectly accurate let's take a look
[Applause]
how did you switch teams so fast
he got treated he got traded and after i
did after i did this after the ally
traded me
we can't have that on our team um
you know
you are uh
a very intense player and uh which is a
great thing much is discussed about
what's called the blake face this is not
the dunking face this is a face that you
give
teammates when you want the ball
you let them know it's
that you want the ball and it is an
intense
it's an expression i've heard it's
intense it's not only when i want the
ball it's pretty much throughout the
whole game um
but i didn't even realize i did it until
one of my teammates kids started
impersonating me yeah chris
chris
chris paul's son did an impression of
you
giving the blake face and it was a great
moment
it's actually very realistic
it's effective though it gets the job
done
let me ask you a quick question you get
fouled a lot obviously you're a
a big threat to the other team
you get hacked more than just about any
other player
and constantly being sent to the foul
line
do you
does it
change or do you think you should change
the way you play is there anything you
can do about that because they are all
over you uh no it happens you know it's
a part of the game
i wish it would happen a little less or
not as hard sometimes but um it's you
know it's one of those things i just
gotta you gotta play through you gotta
understand why it's happening and
deal with it right but you've never
thought like have
other players ever given you advice
about say
here's a way to maybe make sure that
people hack you a little less kobe
gave me some advice i don't think i can
really
say the real advice but basically he
told me to punch everybody
i mean if someone fouls you get up and
punch them punch him just fight he said
fight somebody one time it'll all stop
happening so
but then you'd get in a lot of trouble
wouldn't you because this isn't hockey
it wasn't great advice but
i appreciate it
some advice just start punching people
in the face